markets and incentives for information
thank you guys
you've almost made it to the end of the
week I appreciate those of you who are
still standing at this point so as I
mentioned yesterday I this is a
continuation that is fairly separate
from the talk I gave yesterday if you
are not here yesterday it's fine if you
were here yesterday you can just use the
data co-ops ideas sort of in the back of
your mind to motivate some of the
questions that we'll be talking about
today
so before I start to get into the
economic ideas that I want to discuss in
this two-part discussion today I want to
step back a little bit and have us ask
ourselves why we're studying privacy in
the first place and I suspect if you do
that exercise for yourself at least part
of the answer will be that you believe
that good privacy protections or a good
understanding of privacy can help us
increase the welfare of individuals or
and/or the welfare of society do you
think that you're making people better
off or society better off by
understanding these issues or providing
technology to support privacy and there
are number of different ways.i that you
might think that you're making
individuals or the world's better off
perhaps it's because you're reducing
informational harms perhaps you're
enabling access to valuable data with
new technologies maybe you're protecting
what you see is sort of a fundamental
data right whatever it is though I want
to point to sort of the reason we're
doing this at least I suspect for many
of us is at least in part because we
think we're making something better and
that's basically the motivation for the
talk today because
genomics provides a rich toolkit for
understanding questions of welfare for
quantifying and thinking concretely
about how we make things better and so
if we're gonna introduce privacy
technologies that will maximize or
improve welfare for individuals or for
society there are a lot of things we
need to understand to make sure we're
really achieving those goals so we need
to think about what is the value
provided to individuals from our privacy
intervention what are the other impacts
of these privacy interventions in these
technologies that were suggesting for
example are we increasing access to data
reducing access to data introducing new
social norms giving people an increased
sense of control increased salience see
of privacy concerns which could be good
or bad and we have to think in some way
about how people and society might
behave in response to the new
technologies and the new ideas that we
introduce because privacy is a
significant enough thing that it's not
something that you can address locally
you can't take the current data
landscape in the current world we live
in
come up with a privacy preserving
technology and provide and implement it
here without it having effects that
ripple throughout our lives and
throughout society and so it's important
to acknowledge that and to realize that
there are some tools for trying to think
about the impacts of introducing
technologies and how the entire system
might change and so all this talk about
value might make some of you
uncomfortable why are we gonna now talk
for two hours about things like value or
even something dirty like money we
wanted to live in this you know pure
world of privacy and then I come along
and talk about value so there are good
reasons why you might be
made uncomfortable by this attempt this
exercise of translating everything to
the language of value but I want to
argue that it still may be a really
useful tool so why do we talk about
value I well by translating everything
to value by talking about the value of
the information the value of the privacy
the value of the intervention but we put
everything in one denomination so then
we can talk explicitly about overall
effects and about trade-offs of course
it's complicated when you reduce a
complicated system down to a single
dimension use something and I agree with
that objection that you may be feeling
but it still may be useful and it's
certainly simplifying yes you know
beyond that also in the back of your
mind you're probably thinking this is
problematic in other ways moving this to
the language of value and money isn't
this making data a commodity in some way
that I should be uncomfortable with is
it validating or normalizing privacy
losses that I don't want to validate or
normalize maybe let's try to save those
feelings of discomfort if you're having
them and discuss them later on but I
want to say that this is still hopefully
a useful tool even if you're
simultaneously uncomfortable with some
of the the way of thinking about things
so before we leap into the talk I want
to give you a few caveats and then tell
you what I'm actually planning to do for
this talk
so the first caveat is I'm going to talk
to you today about all sorts of economic
tools that I think are really useful for
people who think about information and
privacy but I'm not an economist I don't
even play one on TV I I am someone who
has spent time thinking about economic
issues I've written economics papers
I've read economics papers I've been to
a lot of seminars and talked with a lot
of economists but I'm still not an
economist by training it's very likely
that there are some of you in the
audience who have significantly more
economics background than I do please
share that so if I'm discussing
a literature and you know more than I do
about it please speak up and share your
insights but I do have some exposure
there but I'm not passing myself off as
an economist the other thing that I
should tell you is that this is sort of
a strange talk that I'm trying to give
you it's not really a survey talk it's
sort of a tasting menu my goal is to
expose you to a wide variety of ideas
and literature's and techniques and
vocabulary that I think are really
relevant to those of us who think about
privacy and data but I'm not gonna cover
an entire literature by any means I'll
sample things that I think are
worthwhile for all of us but this should
be the beginning rather than the last
word so hopefully I'll get you
interested in reading and thinking about
these ideas and getting more exposure we
do we do and then that's a and you know
I count myself at least one foot in the
algorithmic game theory community but a
computer scientists coming up in that
community generally have not gotten
nearly as much training in sort of
traditional and economic tools and
techniques as somebody who's a real
economist so I still I still think it's
important to make that decision that's
it's not the the formal academic
training that I have okay so what's the
plan for the two hours that we have
together so the first thing I like to do
is to basically walk you through a
series of vignettes basically these are
important papers and ideas in economics
that have some relevance to information
and sometimes privacy in particular and
I view this as sort of a basic literacy
that we all ought to have is we all
ought to know some of the really most
important ideas you know some of them
Nobel prize-winning ideas that relate to
information if we're going to go out and
try to change the way that the world
interacts with information and so I'll
go through this sequence of papers and
try to sort of
them to the things that we think about
and put them in some contexts there the
second thing that I'm going to do is
then talk a little bit more specifically
about data and privacy and the ways in
which it does and doesn't act like the
usual sorts of goods that economists
like to talk about sort of try to
understand what work is left to be done
in the space of thinking about privacy
is something that you might offer
guarantee buy or sell then I'm going to
move to talking about a literature much
of which is actually in sort of
theoretical computer science and
differential privacy community but not
all of it on how we think about the
value that individuals might get from
privacy technologies and also on
relating specifically differential
privacy to a number of economic ideas
I'll talk then briefly about how we can
start to quantify the effects of privacy
preserving technologies on society so it
have broader impacts and then at the end
I want to share a couple more of
vignettes of sort of other lessons from
economics that are not necessarily
specifically information related but I
think they're really important for those
of us who are whether we like it or not
designing mechanisms okay so that's the
plan let's start with this sort of
series of vignettes in the space of
economic ideas that relate to
information and before I start I want to
mention that most of the papers that I
am going to mention here and many many
many more are covered by a lovely lovely
survey article of a quiz detailer and
bogman I really highly recommend this
for anybody who's interested in this
space you could use this article is the
basis of a fantastic semester or longer
course or of a reading course and does a
very nice job of organizing and laying
out the ideas and providing all the
references that you'd want in this space
of course the space is an active one so
it doesn't cover everything but it's a
very nice survey
so one of the earliest I economic works
that I know of
they talks about information is Stigler
1961 and this is sort of a some first
effort to think about we know what is
what is the rule of information which
didn't really traditionally have a role
in economic thinking up to that point
and the argument that he makes there is
that in non centralized markets so not
not a market where we all sort of come
to the same place in order to exchange
our goods with one another but one for
example the used car market where you
have if you want to buy a used car you
have to expend some effort to find out
what are the cars that available that
you could buy and what are their
properties and what are their prices so
a non centralized market it takes effort
to find out information about the goods
that are available and their prices and
the idea is that the effort involved in
gathering this information has economic
impact so if you search more if you
spend more time and effort and learning
about the prices and the cars that are
out there then you'll find better deals
for yourself and so this is the one of
the first efforts that I know of to sort
of quantify the role of information and
information gathering in an economic way
and you argues in this paper that it's
very natural that specialized traders so
in the used car example used car dealers
exist and that one of the roles that
they play in a market is to reduce
search costs this is an argument for why
informational e you might see
centralization of markets so I think
already you see immediate connections
the kinds of things that we might be
interested in when we're thinking about
transacting on data and arguments for
why you might see centralized for it for
AI for doing such a interactions the
next should have been yet that I want to
share with you
is Accra loves growth famous 1970 paper
the market for lemons probably many
there's actually I just want to
understand that when I say market for
lemons who who says I've heard that
phrase before but I don't really know
what it means who says I've heard that
phrase before and I could tell you guys
what it means and who says that doesn't
ring any bells
okay like alright so we're in good shape
here all right so it's a market for
lemons what's the idea here the idea is
that information asymmetry can actually
have a really negative effect on a
market in the following sense it can
reduce the quality of the goods that are
for sale in the market so what's the
model here again it's useful to think
about it used cars that's also what I
would think he talks about in the paper
so imagine we're in a world where there
are some used cars for sale and some
buyers who want to buy used cars and
some of the used cars are good peaches
in the paper and some of them are bad
lemons and if you're selling the used
car you have pretty good information
about whether it's a peach or it's a
lemon you know whether it actually got
in accidents you know whether or not you
actually did the required repair work
you know whether or not the guy you
hired to do repair is just you know sort
of tied stuff together with a little bit
of metal wire or if you did the proper
work but if you're the one who's buying
the car it may be difficult or even
impossible to really get information
about whether this is a peach or this is
the lemon so what's the problem with
this information asymmetry so
information asymmetry just means the two
different parties that involved in it in
transaction don't have access to the
same information so the problem here is
that since the buyer has uncertainty
about the quality of the good the buyer
is only going to be willing to pay
something like the average or expected
price of a car that would be in the
market so you know I don't know if it's
peach or lemon but I have some estimate
of the prevalence of peaches or lemons
in the market so up you know pay this
sort of expected value okay but then so
what's gonna happen to the sellers
buyers are only willing to pay the value
of sort of an average car in the market
but you know you have a peach
so you're gonna sell your peach for that
price no way you exit the market so now
what if the distribution look like well
the distribution of cars for sale in the
market just got worse and the average
value just went down and so buyer
potential buyers are willing to pay less
but then you who also have a PhD say
forget it I'm gonna take another lower
price you exit the market can you say
the sort of natural process where the
value of the the items that's for sale
in the market goes down and down and
down and the willingness to pay goes
down and down and down then this is a
phenomenon known as adverse selection
and what observation which you know I
haven't thought about deeply in any way
is that you might actually see effects
related to adverse selection when you
have privacy protections that are opt in
so if instead of providing Universal
privacy protections you have
technologies where people have to choose
whether or not they're going to adopt
this this protection for example you
know they have to actually sign up for
the Do Not Call list and you have an
interesting phenomenon that you don't
have the same distribution of people who
are available to contact as you do on
the Do Not Call list so this you know
may have interesting effects and it may
have sort of an effect on how people get
targeted with advertising because the
distribution of people who did not opt
out is different than the distribution
in the overall population that may drive
further more people to opt out and see
there may be sort of immediate
implications of adverse selection for
those of us who want to think about the
design of mechanisms for people to get
protections or to be present or absent
from a market
the next vignette that I wanted to share
with you is Spencer 73 market signaling
paper what's the idea here what's the
role of information that that's going on
here so here information is showing up
in the form of a signal and what's the
signal in the model so Spence is looking
at the question in some sense of why do
people go to university it takes a lot
of time effort money in some cases why
got way to go to all that effort one
traditional economic explanation for why
people might you know go like a PhD what
were we thinking why would people spend
all of this time on this is because it
makes them better workers more
productive more able to to make money
later on that's a traditional economic
explanation and Spence offers an
alternative explanation which says maybe
not it's not all about making yourself a
more productive worker maybe some of it
is about signaling that you are capable
and so what's the idea the model here
the idea is that maybe it's just easier
for people who are capable workers to
get university degrees and so the fact
that you got a university degree is
evidence that you're a capable worker it
doesn't actually make you a more capable
worker and this idea of costly signaling
is one that is you know gotten a lot of
attention and a lot of recognition and
one of the interesting things that
happens in a lot of these systems is
that you see in many cases that the
aggregate cost of signalling activity
might outweigh the benefits of it so so
you know you have to decide how you want
to design your model and how much going
to university is actually good for
society and how much it's just sort of a
waste of people's time and money but you
can set up versions of this model where
people are wasting a lot of effort on
signaling to each other about their
abilities where if they could actually
just sort of credibly certify their
abilities without having to go through
all the effort of going
University and paying for it that might
actually be better for the system but
it's also costly as activity kind of
signal to other people so consortium has
interests across our systems yeah so
it's a good question I'm so so I I don't
know the literature on crossbow systems
that it uses this civility model but
that's because I don't know that
literature it doesn't mean it doesn't
exist I mean but the basic idea here is
that I you're you there's information
about you that you want to provide to a
future employer or to you know to
somebody you don't have a way to
credibly certify that information and
you know you can't just you know do a
blood test to handle without information
so you have to do something else that
correlates with that information and
doing that something else that
correlates with the information is
really expensive so I don't quite see
the the analogy in the in the Yelp world
yeah so but the key the key idea is that
the cost lays in order for this model to
make sense the the costly signal has to
be correlated with the the ability to
produce the costly signal or the cost
that you incur in producing the costly
signal has to be correlated with your
ability so it has to be easier for good
people to produce papers and you know so
you could think about you know
publications maybe publications are
costly signals maybe what we really want
to do at some level is just you know
tell everybody that we're really smart
but we don't have the ability to do that
but you know the ability to produce
papers is correlated with being really
smart so we go around producing papers
you can tell that story it would be a
similar story I don't quite see the Yelp
connection but maybe it's gonna haven't
thought about it yeah so cost can
definitely be in terms of time effort
money economists like to you know do
that dimension reduction so we put
everything in the same language yeah
other questions about signaling I should
say I don't have slides about this oh
yeah sorry go ahead the extreme model
says that that the university degree is
just about signaling but you can of
course write down a more sophisticated
model that says the university degree is
in part about actually getting useful
you know techniques and ideas in your
head and you know develops your
abilities and your productivity as a
worker but it's also in part doing
signaling it's also in part doing
something else but what you see in a lot
of economic modeling is so the first
model really pairs things down to the
simplest possible scenario where you
just see a single phenomenon and then
later work in the space incorporates
other phenomenon and comes up with more
sophisticated models so it this is not
to say that spends actually believe they
do you know university education was
completely useless assistance' spends
thought this was an interesting setting
in which to illustrate that there may be
something else going on yeah other
questions about saline so I should say I
don't have slides on this but signaling
has gotten sort of a resurgence of
interest in economics and actually also
in computer science but usually most of
the signaling I see these days is sort
of a slightly different type of
signaling instead of this costly
signaling we see a lot of literature
these days and what's known as Bayesian
persuasion and the idea there is there
are lots of settings where there is a
single mediator of some sort who acts on
behalf of a population and has the
ability to signal on behalf of that
population so an example that gets used
is I there might be a prosecutor who
represents many different I clients
before a judge and the prosecutor has
the ability to present the judge sort of
selective information about their
clients all right they can even sort of
explicitly say guilty not guilty is
encoded in there and their eye
interaction and what we see in the
debate in persuasive literature is sort
of an interesting attempt to understand
I how an intermediaries presence can
affect you know who gets convicted and
who doesn't and that they may also be an
interesting connection for us to think
about in in the privacy world i the
first
big introduction of privacy explicitly
to the economic discussion that I'm
aware of is this 81 paper Posner
supposed or is I arguments is that the
concealment of personal characteristics
makes markets less efficient so think of
it as I know in an employment market you
want to get a good job employers want to
get a good employee in order to figure
out who's gonna be a good employee if
they just knew everything they could
know about you it would be much easier
to figure out if you're qualified for
the job but if instead we introduce you
know privacy laws that they can't
actually you know make you do all sorts
of blood tests and produce all your
criminal records and everything
about yourself they have less
information and so they have to expend
all sorts of efforts in order to gather
you know proxies for this information
they maybe have to hire less effective
employees and they would have otherwise
gotten these types of arguments and so
Posner's work predicts that for example
laws that make credit history private
will result in increased interest rates
which would be a symptom of the market
being less efficient and he tries this
out actually sort of looking sort of at
natural experiments where states
introduced various laws that he
considers to be a sort of privacy
preserving was that should make markets
less efficient I should mention I I find
this paper to be pretty non-pc and some
of the discussion that he uses there so
I apologize we're pointing it to you to
it but it's it's an interesting paper I
think it's useful perspective he does
argue in this paper that some forms of
privacy protections do have economic
benefit so privacy is not all bad for
the economy so he gives examples that in
situations where privacy can potentially
increase the value of the information it
can prevent false information from being
privacy regulations of various sorts can
prevent sort of libel or false
information from entering the market
which could be harmful to the market and
there's a recurring theme in economics
of sort of the value of privacy being
that it makes communication more
effective and this relates directly to
something Kobey's at the end of his talk
makes communication more effective
because you don't have to be strategic
in what you say and how you say it
because nobody's listening over your
shoulder and Kobe talked to us about you
know maybe we should think about a post
privacy world and what are the things
that privacy was doing for us that maybe
we can replace with other technologies
and I think this is a common theme that
fits well with that if if one of the
roles of privacy is to make
communication more effective what are
the things we can do that happen
when I see is like it's more effective
because I'm treating everyone my
information about everyone is private
than any persons person X and I'll pay
them all the same this concern day in a
world without privacy that you want to
just be able to tell your doctor you
know I'm a smoker and I do drugs and I
have all these other risks you know help
me make sure my health outcomes are as
good as they could be
but if somebody is listening in and
might do you harm from learning this
information then your communication with
your doctor will be less effective
because you have to say you know I was
wondering if we could run this test you
know just cuz I don't know I have that
disease but which so there's an idea
that you can try to make formal that you
know having I having concerns about sort
of other impacts of the information that
you want to transmit can reduce the
effectiveness at transmission yeah so
eyes so this was the the poster paper
actually is pretty weak on on the model
but it builds on other things it and
relates to other things subsequently the
where there are models involved almost
all of the economic vignettes that I'm
giving you our papers where there was a
model that was very very influential and
I I'm going to talk very very little
about papers where there's significant
data evidence and very little sort of
empirical stuff I think there are
reasons for that and it's not because I
the empirical literature I just found
this to be sort of the the most
prominent interesting convincing
relevant types of papers tended to be
the ones with a model that maybe you
know because that's more the language
that I speak but I think there's also
they're good reasons why it's hard to
use data to argue
wincing ly about the value and impact of
privacy interventions and the role of
data yeah this one has a a small amount
of modeling in it yeah yes are you
familiar with this yes absolutely
horrible paper and some that it probably
killed interest among economists until I
think much more recently where we
started seeing resurgence of interest
among economists for doing much more
sophisticated and much
area of privacy but this was actually a
terrible paper and it even actually be
thrown into the dustbin of history now
an innocent and one more thing to say
and I think you will be represented as
well which is there was this law and
economics movement and and so the
postman was one in particular he maybe
wrote one kind of another Western and
that is guys in more economics basically
where they were so enthralled with with
this particular analysis that they went
around and they wrote papers effective
like this one about every part deep
societal problem because they they go to
consult every problem of this model but
they're kind of painted chose their
example so what you were saying about
the positive that wasn't like people
could benefit they were saying isn't it
funny that privacy advocates are talking
about individual privacy and look the
only people who can really benefit of
corporations they could really benefit
from not being transparent all these
people not turning the whole thing out
there I'm sorry I'm being very strong
about it because I actually think that
this payment do real damage privacy
things because it was well scientific he
was obviously a very influential
brilliant guy i mean you know i yeah i
so I appreciate I appreciate this
perspective and I think I think it's
useful as a both this is a historical
perspective n but I still think that
people should go and read this paper I
think I think it's it okay now you're
going to go read this paper because it's
so controversial you just kill the rest
of this talk it's only gonna get better
from here
okay I don't know the the policies I
it's it's being live-streamed but I I
don't know exactly what the technology
is but I'm we'll discuss
inaudible
well return to that privacy issue after
after we conclude no no I did wait
well we'll talk about it and we'll we'll
come up with a solution so okay so yes
but my next visit the next thing I was
going to say was something more I
reserved I guess along the lines of this
was a very influential paper I think it
did convince a lot of economists that
basically you know privacy is just sort
of mainly a thing that gets in the way
of economic progress you know
information is useful we should you know
why should we let people conceal
information of course there were some
counter arguments that emerged but most
of the work was for a while I mean
basically stopped in this space counter
arguments include that you know
sometimes society benefits when
individuals can select the optimal level
for themselves of an embarrassing
activity so for example we actually
really want people to go to drug
treatment centers and so maybe it's good
if they can do that with some privacy
it's better for all of us and then there
have been a reason I think interesting
related points I and some recent papers
arguing that I when you reduce
information in markets for example in a
job markets but that can have sort of
unintended negative consequences so for
example if we don't give employers
access to information about criminal
records or other eye things that they
might want to have access to when
deciding whether to hire somebody they
may in response rely more on statistical
discrimination strategies so I don't
know anything about you except your race
well when I go based on my you know very
biased priors about what people with
your race do when they get hired into
this role and
there's more to be said here but I think
it's just interesting to connect back
the posner paper okay
so then there was there's a break in
time and in sort of perspective there's
a reason as Helen said that I'm going
from 1981 to 1997 here and it wasn't
really until it wasn't
oh make it make sense in a minute it
wasn't really until I economists
realized oh hey this internet thing
there's something interesting going on
here that they started to return to
thinking about information and also
privacy of course they're exceptions but
there was sort of a gap in the
literature and so there's this paper
from 97 of Varian that talks about a
couple of aspects of personal privacy so
one of them is some from the perspective
of the consumer so say you're somebody
who wants to buy you know a package
vacation and you're going around to
various folks who sell package of
vacations you don't want them to know
exactly what your budget is because then
they will charge you exactly that budget
so you don't want to reveal fully your
willingness to pay you want some privacy
there but are very in argues which you
know you may push back against that
consumers may wish for some information
about themselves to be known because
they may wish to receive advertisements
or offers that are relevant to their
interests and so if you're looking to
buy a beach vacation maybe you want the
folks who sell that to know so they
don't try to sell you a ski vacation
instead the the work of Varian i is one
of the first ones that I know of it
explicitly raises concerns about
secondary uses of data and resale of
data which are really important points
for us to return to them because these
are aspects of data as a good that make
it different than a lot of the other
things that economists are
to pricing and selling and the sort of
one of the things that gets discussed in
this sort of literature that grows out
of here is the concern that both the
person about - about the whom the data
pertains and a person sort of initially
getting access to the data and
interacting with them they can't
anticipate the values and harms that
might come from secondary uses of those
data of those data and so that may not
be properly accounted for in that
transaction there is a literature that
emerged sort of around the 2000s
thinking about property rights for
information which is very relevant to
the discussion that we sort of started
yesterday so there are their arguments
in this work that thinking about
information as a form of property I
could be beneficial both to individuals
and to users of the data that sort of
allows you to assign proper market based
compensation using all the tools that
we've already developed in economics you
know isn't that nice they there are also
very simple models that sort of relate
to the the property rights models that
are introduced I they have some
interesting and disturbing consequences
so for example under a simple model here
a monopolist who's offering personalized
pricing to some people where they have
data about them and fixed pricing if
they don't have it data about you as a
customer can actually convince all of
the potential customers to give away
their data for free because basically
the marginal anonymous consumer doesn't
have any power in this market and so
they're they're sort of disturbing
consequences potentially when you when
you look at some some of these models
yes it's sort of like once everybody is
giving away their data for free you
can't you can't get anything for your
data either it's basically the argument
is sort of a simplified version of this
model and so the you being that last
consumer who who wants who wants to
stand up for your rights to sell your
data you had you have no power in this
market is described that's that's that's
the argument there I mean it's a it's a
simplified model you can argue for and
against it but but they're they're a I
think there are lessons for us even in
this simplified model
[Music]
right yeah thank you yeah thank you for
the reference yeah and I think that's an
important point is that I there are
there is a literature sort of pushing
back against this interpretation of
privacy as a property and property
rights for information and pointing out
some of the problematic aspects there
yeah okay another place where we've all
encountered the role of information in
markets is price discrimination which
has been widely studied and I'm giving
you just one pointer into a very very
large literature they're some of the
work that sort of is moving into the
internet era in this space I suggested
you know through simplified models that
perhaps consumers only need regulatory
protection against price discrimination
if they're naive about how the
information about them can be used of
course they're a naive about how the
information about them can be used so
even if you don't believe this model
uh-huh
you should take it as an argument that
we do need regulation I think but it's I
you know depending on your perspective
you can interpret this in other ways
there's also been some data-driven work
that concludes perhaps not surprisingly
that price discrimination is bad for
consumers but there's a lot of work in
this space on trying to understand you
know how having a specific information
about your consumers and allowing you to
tailor your offer to the individual
consumer effects markets how is this
done not as much as it should be I I so
I am much less familiar with that
literature there is less as far as I
know that's going on that's sort of
convincing an influential of that flavor
a lot from my perspective maybe I'm
missing something a lot that happens in
economics is
of proposed model and then model that
builds on model that builds on model and
there often isn't a lot of a sort of
validation that has consequences for how
seriously the the models got taken but I
don't know and that would be a really
interesting sort of literature search to
do that I haven't done would be to
really try to match each of these sort
of really influential models up with the
most convincing data evidence
maybe I'm just unaware yeah maybe do you
know know something specific but at me I
mean obviously you get into all the
pitfalls of behavioral economic
experiments yeah so I'm gonna get to
some of the problems with trying to use
real-world data to think about this
stuff a little bit later but yeah there
are a lot of problems with it but that's
not to say I mean particularly for
models that have sort of a macro scale
implications as well as the microscope
locations one could presumably do
something to test the implications of
models and I would love to try to gather
those references but I don't have them
finding great rigorous models because
there's a lot of information there a lot
of the parameters or variables that you
just can't actually
but
and that's one of the many challenges
and trying to validate these models that
that many times carry many parameters
yeah yeah but thank you I'd love to get
references that flavor okay so I want to
talk about a couple more perspectives
about sort of who benefits from
information so there's some interesting
work on information sharing between the
lenders so think of this or you sort of
very sort of information chat sharing i
between entities that sort of have a
shared perspective and role in the
market so think of it as you know there
are a bunch of companies that might be
willing to give you loans what's a model
that can explain this phenomenon that we
see that they actually share information
with each other about your past credit
worthiness in your past credit related
behaviors that lets their competitors do
a better job of assessing whether or not
you would make a good customer so at
least from my perspective information
sharing of this sort I mean although it
raises privacy concerns it sounds like
it could potentially be good for
customers because of the implications
that you see from these models that
information sharing between lenders
reduces switching costs because if
everybody knows how good a customer you
are they can all you know offer you
competitive good prices it's not just
the company that you're with that knows
about you and knows whether or not
you're a good bet credit wise but other
companies also know and are willing to
offer you competing lines of credit and
then you're about to anticipate the next
bullet maybe which is that there's
actually bad news for consumers in this
low switching costs which is that it
reduces the need for these companies to
compete with each other to give people a
good initial offer because I can always
steal that customer away later and so in
the analysis that's been done here the
the actual sort of end of fact of this
information sharing is to reduce the
welfare of the borrowers
yeah I mean so there are many many other
things they could it could be harmful to
to bar [ __ ] about the information
sharing but the point of this is that
even something that sounded like it was
maybe gonna be good for the consumer the
idea that you know it's easy to switch
between companies that sounds sort of
like a good thing for consumers because
it sort of pits the companies against
each other turns out it actually in this
model doesn't even have that benefit
[Music]
yeah and that's not a literature I know
well so if you have good pointers that
that would be great yeah sort of more
generally there's been some work on
information sharing between competing
firms which i think is a really
interesting phenomenon and one that i
think is very very relevant to us
because we live in a world now where
there are some major firms competing who
are major players in the data space and
it's really important to understand what
are their incentives and sharing that
information that they have about
consumers so I there's a summary article
which is now kind of old but that
summarizes the then sort of current
literature on the incentive of firms to
share information and there's been more
recent work sort of studying information
design in the sense so what do I mean by
information design this is sort of the
question of what's the optimal amount of
information to share in various settings
so there's interesting work that I think
is very relevant to us in this space and
then sort of back to the question of who
benefits from information there I there
is an interesting model of bored and low
in this paper I it looks at settings
where they're sort of comparing between
consumers being anonymous versus being
trapped by the seller and they they
assume that there's a seller who has a
choice of whether to sort of show you
everything that's in their inventory or
to try to target you know this is the
you know wonder you should buy and just
show you one or a subset and in their
model what they see is that when the
consumers are anonymous the incentive of
the sellers is to provide the full
catalog and when consumers are tracked
what happens perhaps not surprisingly is
that they get steered to the most
profitable products and what happens in
a system that has multiple sellers here
is you get sort of an implicit form of
collusion among the sellers that pushes
people to actually basically not have
access to the products they would have
had if they were anonymous
there is another survey paper that I
want to point you to a more modern one
with a different take on a different
piece of the literature on the survey of
Bergman and Bonacci
and markets for information so this
summarizes I a bunch of their own work
but also has great pointers into sort of
the broader literature here the the main
focus here is really explicitly on
markets and markets for information so
this gets closer even to the discussions
we were having yesterday about data
co-ops so some of the things that they
see so with the single firm purchasing
data you see not surprisingly sort of
price discrimination effects and there's
you know sort of the particular type of
price discrimination effect that C is
known to lower consumer welfare and
overall welfare this of course would
sort of call it to question why a data
intermediary might exist they explore a
number of other models though sort of
maybe not surprisingly but sort of
interesting to see these parameters pop
out in this way that sort of demand and
certainty so sort of uncertainty about
what the consumers want or how much they
want and the informative informativeness
of the information dictate how many
consumers you need in order to make it
profitable to run a data intermediary
and they have some models and some sort
of analysis of how many customers you
need in order to run a data intermediary
and one of the very nice things to point
you to in this article is this quote the
optimal information policy for a data
intermediate eating intermediary remains
a wide open question so there's a bunch
of work that's been done in this space
but there's a lot more yet to do to
understand what it means to sit in the
middle in this space and you know elicit
data from individuals and sell it to
data users how do you price it what do
you information do you provide about the
information that you're selling there's
a lot to be done in this space there's
some nice work that they summarized here
I on how I
it's not immediately obvious I how you
should I how much information you should
reveal as a data inter intermediary
introducing noise naturally lowers the
value of the information that you pass
along but also lowers the cost of
obtaining it and when you think from a
privacy of perspective which i think is
not explicitly incorporated in these
models sort of you see this reinforced
and so there may be a benefit to the
intermediary of transacting on noisy
data this is something that's
interesting to those of us who are
interested in I data intermediaries for
privacy preserving data and then there's
this a concern that we'll see a sort of
again and again in this space that was
first as far as I know it raised in this
86 paper that there was this possible
dilution of the value of the information
you're selling because you leaked
information about its value through
informative prices and so if I tell you
you know you ought to pay this much for
this information it tells you something
about the content of the information
potentially which is an interesting
thing to struggle with data is really
easy to replicate persistent data and
because just seeing the rights there is
some discussion in the literature but I
don't have pointers off the top of my
head I can find them about issues of
resale but most of these models that I'm
talking about right now don't have a
downstream market incorporated so so
there's sort of a known value to the
purchaser of the data and that doesn't
incorporate sort of resale
considerations
not surprisingly there's also literature
in recent ears that's this relevant here
in the space of auctions like sponsored
search
I mean sponsored search is a data market
in some sense and so it's relevant to
look to sponsored search literature
there's also some interesting work on
the sale of information that's
specifically used to reduce risk so if
you want to you know ensure somebody you
can pay for information about them in
order to reduce the risk that you take
on or to understand the risk butter and
sort of how should you price information
in a setting like that and a number of
other issues that come up in this space
that I think are relevant so looking at
consumer scoring is an interesting form
of aggregated data and there's sort of a
whole literature there on sort of
pricing of consumer scores and I could
get you a pointer sorry I dropped the
pointer on this one and also there's
this is just one paper but there are a
number of papers in this space and I
think Steven even has work in this area
so you can ask him
Steven looks shocked I think another
relevant issue is the use of the
Selective release of information to sort
of manipulate the recipient of the
information into helping you do your
machine learning in the sense of being
willing to be one of the Explorer rounds
and explore exploit types of settings so
if you are a company that is telling
people how to drive from A to B in order
to make that happen you need to know
what are the slow roots and what are the
fast roots and that's something that
changes with time so sometimes you need
to send people on good routes that you
know are pretty good and sometimes you
need to send them on routes that you
don't know about so what is the
information that you can provide to them
in order to incentivize them to take
your advice on a route even though
sometimes you're giving them a bum deal
and so that's an important sort of
additional role in sort of modern role
for information specifically in the
context of learning this thing that
seems more like an issue or
a complication of transparency rate as
opposed to individual privacy or not
it's not right I mean there yeah yeah
yeah so it's yeah yeah I know this has
been sort of a lots of different things
so this this I agree as the the the
connection to drivers is not an
immediate one it struck me as relevant
mostly because there are already privacy
concerns about that information that
they've been gathering and then they're
selectively releasing it and it seems
like an interesting layer on top of sort
of these already privacy concerning
mechanisms that then some of that
information is being sort of in a
manipulative fashion return back to some
of the people from whom it was I
collected and then you sometimes get
much less of the value it's this idea
that you've you know there's a
problematic system already where you're
giving information in exchange for
something else but then that's something
else is something based on the
information that may not be sort of what
it was made out to be so there's and
there's something interesting going on
here I don't have a direct immediate you
know sort of privacy problem for this
space but I thought was an interesting
literature to know that there's work
going on of this flavor
example but of the actual is abuse
yeah so the so for example taxi routing
companies in China are actively using
taxis to explore bad routes and things
like this you know they have to do this
all right yeah yeah yeah I mean I'm not
sure I've heard them admit this but i
i've heard other people admit that they
do this but yeah i mean obviously do it
they do it all right so i'm gonna wrap
up for here these parts are not equally
sized so we're not in as bad shape as
you might might expect but one who
returned will sort of quit this
circuitous path through the sort of
economics literature and and focus more
on sort of privacy as we know it i'm not
sure where fits in but vote for
something to add to this collection with
the information cascades where yeah sort
of some hiding information at the
beginning of a process might help cervix
gather enough information to make good
decisions downstream and otherwise you
can sort of wind up in this yeah yeah
yeah that's a great it's a great
suggestion and great let it turn i can
get people pointers if they're
interested there yeah yeah thank you
yeah so this stepping back a little bit
more broadly there are literature's on
understanding how well i groups of
people aggregate the information that
they each personally have so i can take
this even a little bit more broadly to
think about prediction markets and other
ways of aggregating the information held
by individuals so their various
different models about how people might
share the information that they have why
they might share the information they
have and how they might learn from the
information that's already been revealed
by other people and one of the sobering
observations is that in very natural
models where for example we take turns
voting on whether or not i we think that
this faculty candidate should get an
offer so we go around the room saying
yes no yes yes yes yes yes no in a very
simple model where i think that the
other people have useful
information about this candidate we very
quickly stopped saying what we really
believe and start just reflecting the
information that has already been
revealed and so depending on how you
structure the process from for
aggregating information from individuals
the quality of the aggregation can be
potentially very very low and it may
aggregate very little of the information
that was in the room and so there are
lots of models in the space and it's a
great pointer thanks Adam all right so
you should defer more questions to
polish brain
[Applause]